Jaxson to me has been a fascinating
figure not just because he's a Heisman
Trophy winner but also because the fact
he hadn't didn't run to combine didn't
run at the pro day and I thought this
was all based on well Bill Polian is
gonna come out and say that he shouldn't
be a court just a quarterback in this
league he's gonna show Bill Polian and
he's gonna show all the NFL scouts that
this is the way I want to do things and
this is in response to Bill Polian but
then I read Jonathan Jones's story in
si.com called Lamar Jack's and his
mother and the plan they've always had
and I had to get Jonathan on the phone
here on the Rich Eisen show to talk
about this remarkable piece you should
all check out Jonathan thanks for
calling it so the planet they've always
had was what layed out here well you
know look he's a guy he's always been
the most athletic guy that's on his team
and you go back to high school you
transferred into my high school he told
the coach I'm gonna do your quarterback
coach told him like kid get in line he's
season it's practice and he says all
right yep this kid's gonna be my
quarterback but as we all know in high
school the best player on the team a lot
of times goes and plays safety on third
downs you know in big games or it gets
back there for a Hail Mary well it
becomes not about doing that mama
Felicia Jones Omar Jackson's mother
called the coach and said coach we're
not doing that my son's a quarterback
and then she has Bobby Petrino promised
her while sitting on their couch at the
South Florida home that he's going to
play Lamar Jackson at quarterback in
quarterback only well during a practice
freshman year they have him go back to
punt returner see what you can do
because they were struggling about
position in the mama well or they could
really get back into the coaches offices
because he's had a call from Felicia
Jones literally doesn't look like
quarterback to me coach and so for a
very long time Felicia Jones has had
this plan that her son was going to be a
quarterback and so far that plan has
paid off in the form of a Heisman
trophy-winning sophomore season a better
statistical season as well as on film at
his junior year and now he's trying to
be a first round this is the plan
they've always had and and obviously it
has worked out to this point how is it
working out as he is trying to be
drafted as
as possible as a quarterback in the NFL
without an agent and with his mom acting
as such Jonathan there's been a so much
conversation that this is foolhardy when
it all comes down to it what can you
tell me about how it is playing out in
in reality boots on the ground here well
certainly it would appear or at least it
sounds foolhardy coming from NFL types
coming from the agents of course this is
certainly unconventional objectively and
so because it's unconventional because
it hasn't been done a lot of people
think that it shouldn't be done this way
well I don't know that it can't work I
mean if you look at their history
Heisman Trophy winning season
you know I first-round quarterback he
could be drafted anywhere really from
kind of 12 to 72 he has a pretty good
plan and so if you believe that your
plan has worked this long I understand
why you would believe it would continue
to work but of course you know the big
leagues so you know teams are having
trouble getting in touch with Felicia
Jones and Lamar Jackson I do not know
because they are fiercely private and
would not politely would not grant an
interview to me for a number of requests
that I asked for so I don't know if this
is they're difficult to get in touch
with because they don't like answering
their phones I don't know if they're not
picking up calls from teens that have
established quarterbacks but are both
willing to accept a call from let's say
the LA chargers who have an aging
quarterback until rivers 36 will be 37
at the end of the season certainly they
met with him after the produce he's
gonna have a workout with the Dolphins
of course a lot of people are kind of
Arizona Cardinals with Sam Bradford only
being on a one-year deal it seemed more
inclined to go to those places where he
said yeah it's okay if I have to sit out
for a year and be behind a veteran but
clearly I think his camp wants him to be
able to be in a position just like when
he was going to Louisville but he has an
opportunity to start if not in year one
and certainly in year two Jonathan Jones
of the mmq b and si.com joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show and it's
inevitable we're gonna hear it you know
helicopter mom you know
on her around your organization look at
rely apples mom blah blah and blah how's
that gonna play on it's interesting
right because everyone wants to kind of
compare her to an Eli Apple well I even
said that to one scout that was put in
it yeah but what more Jack's is actually
a good guy somebody said you know you
know people even had somebody who
compared her to Oh Lavar Bowl or Todd
Marinovich is dead but you know those
folks were really in the eye of
everything they wanted to be out in
front they wanted to be spokespeople
like I said Felicia has had ample
opportunity to put herself out there to
grab these endorsement deals to do
whatever they want and she has decided
to stay private
really throughout his college career and
certainly she's continuing that now so
is she this stage mom who just wants to
be out front I don't think so but does
that mean that she's not pulling the
strings absolutely she is anything the
fact that he hasn't signed an
endorsement deal yet anything on that
front you know it's strange I thought
for sure as when he came out there and
adidas but he was going to put on some
Adidas shoes and he's gonna see this
athlete right and then he puts on Nike
cleats and who knows what's going on it
seems like it's an easy check sitting
out there another part of this
unconventional deal that's going on
where again are they driven by money
well it's an easy check just to sound
with adidas Under Armour or Nike and so
far it appears that they have not done
it is there just something based on your
reporting that once upon a time somebody
wanted to put Lamar Jackson in a box
other than quarterback and it it scarred
them or something obviously look it's
the bits it's the best most well paid
position on the field and it obviously
it's the one with the biggest spotlight
and you can get the biggest stage I'm
just wondering you know where where it
all started
potentially the job no it certainly you
know Bill Polian when he said the wide
receiver thing then we had we had the
report at the combine that teams were
asking to have him work out there and
then he refuted that report and then we
all were trying to figure out what the
team's asked him and then we got into
this big semantic battle right but as a
lot of people when I was reporting this
story said to me I have no doubt that he
could play wide receiver and he could
play wide receiver very well I've no
doubt he could be a great punt returner
this guy
is really a dynamic athletic playmaker
but his positions quarterback that's
what he knows how to play and is here
all absolutely so or every other it was
every other quarterback in this draft to
a certain degree but I would say to this
I would say to them he showed steady
progression from freshman to sophomore
to junior year I thought he looked
really good at pro day if you're looking
for somebody who yes he was wrong going
into Louisville coming out of high
school to where he is now and seeing
that progression that should be a
positive to any decision oh there's no
doubt I mean there's no doubt the guy's
a dynamic player he's spectacular and
we're talking about a 21st century
League that takes more and more from the
college game puts it in the rpoS the
Eagles just RPO their way with Nick
Foles who doesn't even give you the
threat of the run all the way to the
Super Bowl podium and we saw what -
Shawn Watson did last year when he got
in so last question for you here
Jonathan I'm looking at the mock draft
of Mel Kiper he's got him 22 overall of
the bills and then the mock draft
of of McShea 'he's these are just out
today from ESPN 29th overall to
Jacksonville do you think that we'd be
hearing about lamar jackson top ten if
he had the more conventional setup of
agent pound in the table talking to
team's 24/7 365 right now as well as
being easier to find his client being
yeah do you think they were talking to
teams and also talking to media right
having a friendly agent rich you know
how about how the deal goes right is the
agent is there's very much a you scratch
my back I scratch yours and a lot of
sports media certainly an NFL media
certainly with a lot of these super
agents so if he had one of these guys
and maybe he's influencing some of these
some of these people who are putting out
mock drafts but I'll tell you this I'll
be very surprised if he's lasting to 29
especially as we all consider that
there's going to be a run on
quarterbacks early on that people are
going to jostle to try to get into that
top five top six for those four
quarterbacks everyone seems to think are
the top four I think that we're gonna
start getting into the teens and folks
are gonna say this guy is too dynamic we
love to fit your option too much if he
has to sit out a year that's fine but we
have to have this guy on our team and I
don't think that he's gonna make
to the 20 yeah I mean why would Arizona
pass on him on 15 right my gosh and then
you know obviously the Chargers are
sitting there at 17 if if that's the
team that that kind of got past the if
you will pearly gates right at the pro
day he's really special I mean when we
and we chatted with him right Brockman
in his Iseman trophy here it did really
enjoyed getting to know him and meet him
when it all said and done Jonathan how
do you think his professional prospects
will be in this league well you know as
you mentioned I'd you know I said the
teams because of Arizona and because of
LA I think that just like we saw with a
Pat mahomes this past season he was look
he is wrong and it's not it's fine to
say that it's fine to say that he has
plenty to learn and so it's I think it
would do him well to sit out a year to
not have baptism under fire but when you
consider how he can make plays with his
leg his arm talent that he can make a
lot of throws he doesn't turn the ball
over oh I think he's willing to take
that SEC we see so many times he's doing
thread quarterbacks who think that their
legs are going to be able to get them
out of pressure situation and they make
really poor decisions his legs are
better than anyone elses legs at this
position since Michael Vick and he still
understands that sometimes the best play
is to just throw the ball away or to
just eat it and take the sack that's
what I love about Lamar Jackson as a
young prospect and so I can because he
has that instilled in him and this isn't
some recurring thing where he loves to
throw the ball to the other team like
two of the quarterbacks in the top floor
you know and Arnold or Josh Allen I
really like that I think that continues
into his professional career Jonathan
appreciate the time great article great
column
thank you I read we got at Jay Jones 9
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience